fitting in with the auradon kids wasn't
easy at first but you learned the ropes
pretty quickly Mel on this surface you
guys were completely different but once
you dug a little deeper you realize that
the AKS and decays weren't so different
after all in the end you guys are
happiest when you're singing and dancing
the night away and Dave we're not
complaining about it because let's face
it you brought us some of the best
musical numbers that Disney Channel has
to offer
smell is used to being number one and
Audrey and uma used to have a problem
with that but will one of mouse songs
make it into the top three or will she
lose her spot to her former rivals watch
out now because if there's one thing oh
man Audrey can do just as good as you
it's put on a show let's jump right in
with number ten one kiss
DB has got it all from looks to various
talents to an amazing personality true
love's kiss
works every time well we haven't
actually used that word yet and her song
one kiss embodies all of that and more
in just a few short months one kiss
amassed over 54 million views on YouTube
alone which brings Eevee song in at
number 10
Eevee was long overdue for a solo and
this one was simply perfect
while singing the song Eevee broke dug
sleeping spell with an act of true love
we loved how nervous she was come on
Evie don't doubt yourself
you're Doug's true love through and
through space between if you're staying
I'm staying to know maybe you are an
Oregon girl coming in at number nine is
the heartwarming duet space between this
number is a fan favorite for many
reasons one of them being that it's a
ballad that supports true friendship
despite Evie bean mouse best friend she
chose to keep her true feelings of
outward on hidden but this song which
has over 56 million views served to
remind the Betsy's
no matter what happened between them or
where they chose to live they'd always
have a place in each other's hearts
night falls night falls from The
Descendants 3 soundtrack comes swooping
in at number 8 this group number has
already accumulated over 100 million
views in a few short months fans love
this song for obvious reasons first of
all it showcased the core 4 and Oommen
are pirates fighting together for the
first time and second of all it's
choreography was out of this world you
and me you and me makes a splash at
number 7 reminding us of how important
it is to be ourselves you and me was the
last song of descendants 2 and it
concluded the sequel perfectly since it
first came out in 2017 it's accumulated
over a hundred and fifty eight million
views proving just how inspirational it
can be the core poor and the AKS
celebrate the cotillion after sending
uma packing we loved this song because
it marked the beginning of Carlos and
jeans love story
chillin like a villain when it comes to
group numbers mal usually takes the lead
but that just wasn't the case for the
hit song chillin like a villain
instead it smells a right-hand woman who
steals the show and she doesn't
disappoint with Carlos and Jays help
Evie tries to teach Ben how to look and
feel like a villain we love how awkward
Ben looks on the aisle but hey he was
getting the hang of it by the end this
song has over a hundred and seventy six
million views and we're not even close
to number one yet if only if there's one
VK who's got solos down pat it's the
future queen of auradon but granted at
this time now had no idea that you would
one day rule over what she swore to
destroy if only is a beautiful song that
shows just how much mal is struggling on
one hand she wants to make her mother
proud but on the other hand she's
falling head over heels in love with Ben
if only comes in at number 5 with over a
hundred and eighty seven million views
it's going down despite having over a
hunch
96 million views it's going down comes
in one spot short of making it into the
top 3 but there's no denying that this
iconic song made way for one of the
coolest battles of the descendence
franchise Malan Numa face off in a rap
battle and things get personal real
quick this action-packed number is a
hard one to forget now let's find out
which songs made it into the top three
ways to be wicked surprise surprise ways
to be wicked made it into the top three
best songs of The Descendants franchise
with over 240 million views wicked ways
beneath the skin let all who taste it
now join in this opening number sets the
pace for descendents - reminding us that
our villains gone good still have a
taste for wickedness or at least mouth
still does everything from the lyrics to
the music to the choreography is off the
charts now let's find out who the
runner-up is rotten to the core
before our favorite villains became the
coolest kids in auradon they ran the
isle like it was nobody's business brawn
to the core is the runner-up with over
three hundred and sixty-six million
views this track is the first song of
the franchise and it doesn't disappoint
but there's one song that knocked it out
of the park and we're not talking in
regards to views we're talking about the
solo number that made it into the
Billboard Hot 100 can you guess what it
is queen of mean you're new here aren't
you I'm Audrey princess Audrey Sleeping
Beauty's daughter you guessed it the
queen of mean is the best song ever and
it isn't sung by Mel but rather by her
former rival Audrey Oh Audrey now can
steal your crown your man and your
status but she definitely can't steal
your breakthrough song which one of
these songs is your favorite sound off
in the comments and that's a wrap if
that subscribe button and don't forget
to give this video a big thumbs up
thanks for watching we'll catch you next
time on the things
[Music]